For centuries, humans have stared at cats and wondered, "What are they thinking?"
When a cat purrs, we tend to assume it's saying, "I'm happy."
Wrong.
It's more complicated.
Research shows cats do purr when they're happy...
...but also when they're injured or sick.
It means they want you to stick around whether it's for cuddling or for care.
In other words, a purr means something like, "Don't go anywhere, please!"
How about when your cat rubs against your legs after you come home from work?
You might think it's just asking for food or attention.
Not exactly.
In the wild, cats who have finished up a hunt will come back and rub their pals...
...like Vikings giving warrior hugs.
A rub means something like, "We are reunited, old friend!"
"I have missed thee!"
What about meowing?
It turns out that cats almost never meow to communicate with other cats.
It's a behavior they seem to have adopted as a way of trying to talk to humans.
In fact, there's no universal "meow" language.
It's tailored to a cat's owner.
A 2003 study showed that only a cat's owner can correctly guess...
...what his or her cat is meowing about.
So, if you hang out with your cat enough, you, and basically only you...
...will know if it's begging for food, asking for help or just saying it's bored.